now my personal opinion if you still
have the old twin motion installed with
a computer
and you don't need to upgrade for any
reason
make sure you just keep using it until
they fix these bugs because they're very
annoying
having said that if you're ready for the
next leap in rendering technology
twin motion 2020.2 truly
and i mean truly steps it up this time
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me
if you're a long time subscriber thank
you so much for being here
on this channel we talk about all things
architecture and technology related
so if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below and let's get on with
this video
so like i mentioned at the start of this
video we're talking about twin motion
2020.2 today we're going to be looking
at all its brand new features
the good the bad and unfortunately
they're very ugly
i've been fortunate enough to be
designing some very high level
extremely confidential things this week
but it's given me
the opportunity to play around with
archicad 24
and also play around with the brand new
twin motion 2020.2
now the reason i've prefaced this with
saying the very ugly is because
straight off the bat no lies twin motion
crashes
so much with this new update it has
driven me
to the near brink of destruction how
many times it has crashed on me
every single time that you load it up
something else forces it to crash
when you're getting started it's either
the lights the plants
the location i don't know what else
crashed it but i swear it crashed at
least
40 times in me trying to export
one video given this was an extremely
large project it was
very labor intensive on my computer but
at the same time i've had enough time
now to actually test it on a much
smaller project
and again it still crashes continuously
now alongside a ui refresh some icons
moving around
some logos changing here and there it
has had a huge
graphical improvement twin motion 2020.2
is now able to render textures in a lot
more detail
we now have more details in the shadows
less blown out highlights
more understanding of how the sun works
how the paths move
and how the people move we have the
ability to do so much more to make our
renders
look so much better now the pc you see
behind me is a custom built
4k architecture machine i had it custom
built a couple years ago to help me get
through my masters architectural studies
and it did exactly that it was purpose
built
to be able to run some of the highest
rendering softwares
known to man at the time thankfully i
invested a little bit more money at the
time and made sure it could future proof
itself i've also recently upgraded the
ram and a few other bits and pieces
to keep up with 2020 now that twin
motion has had new update
2020.2 i'm just saying 2020 a lot in
this video sorry guys
it is starting to struggle with that
update when i put the settings onto
ultra
it starts to lag and really really slow
down
so for most of the time i tend to run
this on either medium or high
just to get it across the line and then
when i need to export and render i plug
it into ultra
and get phenomenal results one of my
personal favorite updates in this new
2020.2 version
is simple parametric and opening doors
i've always wanted the doors in my
scenes to animate especially when making
videos
if you're an architecture student
watching this make sure you learn and
spend some time to make high quality
videos
in my opinion it is no longer just about
how good
your photo rendering skills are you have
to be
really really good at video rendering as
well clients in my industry are starting
to
expect it not demand it anyway the
moving doors have actually added such a
unique feature to this program
to be able to animate the doors so
easily or to even just drop doors in
from their library that are fully set up
and ready to go
makes these projects so fun to work with
i created a video today where the
sliding door opened the camera panned
out
and it was all flawless the door was
triggered as the camera came towards
and it looked really really good now i
know you were able to do this previously
in twin motion versions
but it was a nightmare to set up it
still is pretty complicated though
if you are looking to animate doors make
sure you jump on a tutorial from
somebody else i'm not going to make a
door tutorial
and it takes about 30 seconds of your
time to just learn how to set up these
doors
but once you get it it is great addition
to all your video renders
another feature in this update is the
new phasing technique
now yes again phasing was available
before in previous twin motion versions
however it wasn't this simple they've
made phasing
so easy and so simple to use that you
can phase
a whole construction process from the
day the truck arrives on site to the day
you hand over the keys to the client if
you wanted to
obviously it's going to take a bit of
time you're going to have to spend a lot
of time detailing each individual scene
but you can easily toggle things on and
off and truly get a sense of the
building
being constructed now along with the new
phasing they're putting an emphasis
on the early days of construction which
means they've updated
a whole bunch of construction vehicles
we have a whole new array of different
construction vehicles that can now be
edited
beyond the generic yellow color they had
in the last version
you can now make them a little bit more
attune to your company
to your preference or however you really
want them to be
now they didn't just stop at
construction vehicles they went to town
on the editing features of aircrafts and
vehicles
there's a whole bunch of new vehicles
added but more importantly the features
that they've added to the aircrafts
means you can almost model an entire
airport
dedicated to your brand if you wanted to
go ahead and
chuck your logo on the back of a wing of
an a380
you can do that now if you wanted to
custom paint the bottom
neon pink and the top lime
yellow i don't know why you would but if
you wanted to
you could now this isn't something
that's going to get used a lot in the
architecture profession because
obviously
designing airports is a very niche topic
in itself
architecture is a niche already but
having this freedom and
ability to create something like this is
a really nice touch
another cool feature about the aircraft
is you can actually put
a like button on the end of the tail or
you can slap
a little subscribe sticker so if you
wouldn't mind doing a favor make sure
you smash that like button down below
guys
help this video with the youtube
algorithm and if you're enjoying it
want to see more of my content make sure
you subscribe down below as well
something that i'm very happy to see is
the addition of 15
new trees they haven't just gone ahead
and added 15 new trees from the east
asia region
they've actually developed these trees
into a three stage
maturity cycle so now you have a sapling
adolescent and a mature tree that slowly
ages as the time progresses
so if you are phasing or if you simply
just want different
age-appropriate trees you can model that
however you want
unfortunately these trees are still very
very glitchy in my
personal experience i've had them one
not want to change seasons manually so
when you go into the settings and try to
change the season from summer to winter
for example
they won't change at all changing their
age they tend to be very jumpy there
isn't a natural progression in them
and when you decrease the quality of
your render they don't look
as good but that one's kind of not here
nor there that's expected
now twin motion has gone ahead and said
that they've increased the quality of
the puddle
and rain simulation in twin motion 20
20.2
in my personal opinion i believe they've
actually
enhanced all of the seasons and the time
of day as well
i've never seen twin motion so crystal
clear
so i don't know lifelike i guess
that it has improved so much in such a
short period of time
i think since epic games took over and
bought out the company it has improved
dramatically
yes it's still super glitchy and super
buggy and crashes all the time
but if you can push through those
problems in those areas
it truly does create a very beautiful
masterpiece at the end of the day so
those are some of the best features
that twin motion has brought out in the
2020.2 update
but with the good obviously comes the
bad
like i mentioned before twin motion
crashes all the time now
it's crashing on me when i add lights
when i change plants
when i go to save it when i go to close
it which was an interesting one
every time i try to close twin motion it
would save first of all thank god
and then it would crash definitely
something to look out for if you're used
to clicking the close button and waiting
for the do you want to save this
project little window you're not going
to get that opportunity if you hit that
cross button too early
on the positive side when you're syncing
between archicad
and twin motion i'm assuming it will be
the same for revit
and everything else it actually syncs a
lot smoother and a lot quicker
it definitely takes a long long time
to finalize all the materials and
generate the shapes
when you're first synchronizing it or
when you're re-synchronizing it after a
crash
but in between when you're just fixing
mistakes and doing
real-time rendering it works really
really well
something that i noticed pretty quickly
is that lights
no longer work in the same way they used
to previously
now don't get me wrong this is a good
thing because you used to have to put
lights
throughout your whole internal building
to be able to get
some sort of internal render and
lighting an internal scene is very
difficult it takes a lot of time to get
it right so usually
i'd personally just flood the whole
scene it would look terrible
now lighting is no longer controlled the
same way
obviously natural daylight is so
powerful that during the day you should
be able to see
inside if it's a well done design if you
put a light source in
to a daily scene now you will not see
that light
very bright unless you pump it up all
the way once it goes night time
then that's a different story these
lights will slowly fade on
the issue here being the words slowly
fade on
when you take your time bar settings
through the day and go from
sunrise mid-afternoon sunset night
time that transition between sunset and
night time is very abrupt
it's almost instant from yellow golden
hour
pitch black lights slowly start to fade
on and you see
night time i think this will get fixed
in a hotfix very quickly
so that shouldn't be too much of an
issue when you're watching this video
it's probably already fixed because that
was a pretty major one that really
annoyed me
and i'm sure everybody's going to have
that issue because there is so many
times i've done renders and there's a
nice gradual
sunset to fade out dark scene which you
can't do at the moment
something to be mindful of as well is if
you're running it on medium quality low
quality
or whatever you aren't running it on
ultra quality
when it comes time to export and you've
created all your scenes and all your
videos
and you hit that export button and
you're still on
medium for example it's going to render
out these images
to medium quality that seems a bit odd
to me you'd think once you hit render it
would do the absolute best it could
but no you have to actually go in change
it to ultra
and not only that you have to go back
through each individual photo in each
individual video
and refresh that scene for it to know
that you want it to export in ultra i
originally exported all my images
and all my videos in medium quality
because my computer unfortunately
couldn't handle
that particular project and all the
images came out blurry and garbage
so it took me a little bit of time to
figure out what went wrong
in that rendering scene when i did
actually change it to ultra and went
through one by one
huge pain but it did end up rendering it
perfectly this like i said before
the quality of the renders is so much
higher now they've definitely set
a new standard now by putting that
emphasis on the quality i think they've
also
tried to tell a story in the whole
construction sequence
and to create an ambience around the
project they've gone ahead and updated
all the vehicles construction and
otherwise
they've updated tons and tons of people
heaps of new characters all sorts of
different color palettes
and different motions that they do now
they've updated all the lighting
they've updated a bunch of furniture all
the trees
they've really gone ahead and really
tried
to tell the story better you're no
longer just placing
one building in an empty box you really
want to create
that whole scene from the road to the
curb
to the markings on the road to the rain
the puddles
it really and truly does become a story
and a narrative that you're telling
and even though this update has so many
problems and crashes all the time
i still think it is a great update from
twin motion
anyway that's all from me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below to help it with the
youtube algorithm you'd think it doesn't
help but it truly truly does so i'd
appreciate it if you would
if you want to see more of my videos
smash that subscribe button down on the
other side
and i will see you next monday